[Music]
welcome to Startalk I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist and
of course your host we are returning to
our sort of medical professional in
chief dr. Irwin redlener you may
remember him from a previous episode
he's the director of Columbia
University's National Center for
disaster preparedness
he's also a professor at Columbia
University's medical school this is
being recorded on April 23rd of course
you need to date everything that
involves a discussion about the corona
virus because things change daily so we
just want to get an update on that last
conversation we've had with him which
was in fact back on March 3rd which
seems like forever ago and so I think
since then or when did we miss it was it
after then her before then was
officially declared a pandemic I think
it was just before was officially
declared a pandemic by the World Health
Organization are they the ones with the
power to do that I mean could you have
declared it a pandemic without one I did
but nobody cared but yes I did but no
but and people were already thinking
that it should have been declared a
pandemic before whu-oh stated so and
there was a lot of reluctance by the way
because you know what you say we have a
global pandemic and a global emergency
you've elevated the conversation quite a
bit and the criteria for a pandemic
is a deadly outbreak in a particular
place that all of a sudden begins to
cross international borders so it
becomes that's the pan in the demmick
and that is started to happen way before
the World Health Organization declared
to be so and if I remember correctly
social distancing was not yet a thing to
be to be invoked correct certainly not
in the way that it's evoke now we're
sort of talking about it vaguely and by
the way
this really terrific expert named Mike
osterholm in Minnesota has suggested we
don't even use the term social
distancing that we use physical
distancing and he makes the point that
we don't actually want to be socially
listed we want to try to use whatever is
available like zoom and FaceTime and
whatever phone calls
to try to sustain and amplify our social
connections so I just recently started
having read him be interviewed on this
subject started referring to this
process as physical distancing I think
it's a good idea I will be happy to do
that going forward especially since of
course we are not socially distanced at
this point we are right next to each
other yes we are yes electronically
neighbors I just remember it was only
two weeks after we had our last
recording with you where I had started
recording Startalk
out of my home so things were happening
fast and millions worldwide have been
affected tens of millions had filed for
unemployment new york city has become a
global epicenter and so could you update
me on the hospitalization rates and some
of the statistics related to testing
versus who's hospitalized and what the
the respirator the state of respirators
are
sure so let me a little bit of a
background here's probably worthwhile so
right now it is anticipated that at
least 50% of the world and including the
US and maybe as high as 60 or 65% will
contract the virus that's responsible
for kovat 19 and its formerly called the
SARS Co v2 is the name of the virus but
in any case we expect let's say half the
u.s. population that's about a hundred
and sixty million people will actually
get infected and somewhere between ten
and fifteen percent will have to go to
the hospital and and so the vast
majority of people will get either zero
to very moderate symptoms that could be
cared for at home but we'll have about
that let's say it's fifteen percent go
to the hospital and about five percent
will end up actually in the ICU
requiring a mechanical ventilator which
means a breathing machine
so a tube was put down your throat it's
connected to basically a pressure
machine there's forcing air and oxygen
into your lungs there's been a very
interesting problem the I think you'd
probably be interested in so there's a
group of professionals called modelers
and modelers take certain assumptions
like what is the infection Raider what
is it likely
what are we likely to see in terms of
percentage need to go to the hospital
and they create projections of what the
future has in store for us when it comes
to let's say something like a pandemic
those modelers are currently all over
the map to the point where there's so
many different assumptions you could put
in and there's so much unknown about
this particular virus that when they're
whispering into the ears of people in
government I don't have to make
statements order mechanical ventilators
order protection personal protection
equipment and so on and some others are
saying you know what we're gonna need
another hundred thousand mechanical
ventilators that your and another mother
says no well our calculation is only
twenty thousand that
kind of disparity has become very
prevalent to the point where you know
nobody's really trusting the modelers
and I hope no modelers elicit this
doesn't they're really very nice people
but but the fact is you know these
models are totally depending on the
information putting in and since we have
so much uncertainty a lot of different
assumptions could be put in so because
there was seemingly such a tremendous
demand and a tremendous need to build
more hospital beds especially ICU beds
we had the Army Corps of Engineers who
are a wonderful very talented group of
people that connected with Department of
Defense they came from for example to
New York to a huge convention center
called the Javits Center and built a
2,500 bed hospital and then the army or
the military's also sent up a a hospital
ship called the Comfort to be docked in
the New York Harbor to give you in more
beds turns out we're not going to need
many of those beds and the theory though
was that and be better to over plan than
under plant except the problem with this
Niang has been that every single city in
the country anticipating their own surge
maybe not as steep as New York's were
pretty steep we're all demanding things
at the same time and since the federal
government was so extraordinarily and
profoundly disorganized and you know
have these weren't incompetent in
creating national plans and settling
national priorities we ended up having
some places with more than they need
other places who don't really have much
need right now but probably will in the
near future it's it's not a thought
through plan with the amount of federal
oversight and direction that we might
have hoped for alright so so let me get
back to the modeling comments just for a
moment so we do a lot of modeling and
astrophysics and we would pass judgment
on a model based on whether there were
too many loose ends that were sort of if
not arbitrarily tied together we're at
least
even if you had a good reason for
assigning a value in one place or
another if there are 10 or 20 different
values you start getting noise after a
while you start getting something you
can't trust so let me just ask you what
are some of the input parameters to
these models I know one of them would be
if you have the disease what's the
average number of people that would
contract it from you that's a very
important number correct exactly and
originally was 2.3 so a little more than
two people would likely be infected by
you but there's now this recent data to
suggest it may be somewhere between five
and six people and the multiplier effect
from that just that difference of
infectivity has a tremendous outcome or
output that is befuddling and it makes
the control this much more difficult
one of the things that we have to do in
controlling the spread of a virus like
this is to do something called contact
tracing so if you turn out to have a
positive test somebody resembling the
help arm will pull you up and say let's
go over your last two weeks of we've
been in touch with where have you been
and let's try to figure out who can we
who we need to call to make sure they
get tested so if you're only let's say
infecting on average two other people
that's one thing if you're infecting on
average five and a half people that
makes that job of contact tracing
horrendously more complicated difficult
and expensive right now by the way we
have about 2,200 people who are
designated contact Tricia's in the
United States and some people are now
estimating we need over a hundred
thousand some as high some people are
saying sighs three hundred thousand
people who could do contact tracing if
we're gonna get control of this and part
of that it's based on the fact that we
think the disease is more infectious
than it was so this notion that you be
infecting two other people are six other
people that's of course greatly
mitigated by physical distancing right
so so if you say the rate is this and
then so please engage in physical
distance young and then everyone does
that number drops and that changes the
marble right and the other thing I'm
just gone on about this but the fact is
if we're not doing testing which we're
doing some but nowhere near as much as
we need to
we don't really know who's positive we
if we could test the entire population
right now we could we could say well
these public health interventions like
physical distancing wearing masks when
you do go outside and so on could
potentially have such and such effect
but if we don't even know the baseline
of how many people are infected and
who's infected that obviously throws a
monkey wrench into this entire challenge
that we have so the part as I understand
it correctly part of what makes this
virus particularly insidious is the
incubation period before you even have a
symptom that would indicate that they
might have it so and York are you
contagious over that time yes so this
has also been a point of controversy so
most people it is thought between the
time of contact or contracting the
infection and the time of getting
symptoms if you're going to be in the
category people get symptoms is about
five days but the incubation period is
somewhere between two or three days on
the one end and fourteen days on the
other end so if you've had a contact
with contact with somebody who's
positive and you know you don't get
tested and you don't have symptoms
within a two-week period of time you're
not likely to be popped to be positive
so there's that but then if you're
talking about a population of 328
million people even small percentage
changes can have huge differences in the
output in the outcome of your your
modeling analysis so becomes very
complicated dr. oz famously said the
other day about the only thinks we
should open schools again all over the
country in which case he says we'd only
get another two or three percent
fatality rate which it's millions and
millions of people if you think about
the entire population in the US so we
have to be careful
even about small numbers when we're
talking about what what's going to these
modeling imprints so what you're saying
is a small percentage on a huge number
is a lot of people and a little
newspaper headlines for so that brings
me to the question about a possible
second wave this coronavirus got me
reading about the 1918 flu pandemic and
there are multiple waves and it went
away and it came back so we started you
started by saying we might ultimately
have half the population in the United
States having been infected with the
corona virus presumably that's spread
over some period of time that would
presume multiple waves so that we do
flatten the curve we don't overrun the
beds but still it runs its course again
this presumes it's before we have a
vaccine so could tell me about second
waves and and how do you how do we how
do we mitigate that well essentially
might be my feeling now is that a second
wave is inevitable and possibly a third
wave after that and this is the reality
of it which of course brings us the
course whoa
now what if that's going to be the case
then I think we're at some reprieve
prepared for a lot of interventions that
are of a physical separation and
sheltering in place type before we have
an effective vaccine which is still a
year to a year and a half away even some
very very much accelerated research to
get a vaccine development out to market
so we're in for a long haul Neil this is
one of the things I've been trying to
grapple with for myself personally as
well as for all the rest of us because
what does this mean I'm now not in my
where I usually life is very very
different I'm not sitting next to you as
well as was the case when we last had
this kind of conversation and what if it
goes on for months and months and months
what if it goes on for a year and by the
way we're not
even sure that this particular virus
will be amenable to a an effective
vaccine and it may not be so the some
who have speculated that we might be
seeing annual recurrences of this
particular virus and annual
reinstitution of the physical separation
and and the you know having meetings
digitally via the internet for the
foreseeable future I think eventually
we'll get this tackled but if you're you
know you're if you're planning you know
your your weddings were next fall I
would be thinking about making sure you
don't have a non-refundable deposit
placed I think you know hate to be so
all right so place over before we go to
our commercial break give me something
hopeful just to get us through the
commercial we're actually learning a lot
in two ways Neal one is we're learning a
lot about our ability to adapt and to
our you know our ability to become more
resilient as people on which is really
great there's a second thing let's say
for after the commercial but it's really
important oh okay we'll come back to the
other half of a positive combination
from dr. Irwin redlener when start off
return
welcome back to you start off I'm here
with dr. Irwin redlener director of
Columbia University's National Center
for Disease preparedness disaster Sue's
me disaster preparedness which it's got
to be like the coolest business card
anyone has ever carried let's pick up
some of where we left off we were trying
to to understand what could be a
recurrence multiple recurrences which
would happen if according to your early
comment half the population would
ultimately get the disease
what would you say that all of our
social distancing or physical distancing
has done the job well it's the only tool
we have let's put it that way we don't
have a specific medication that will
treat Cove 8:19 we certainly don't have
a vaccine so whatever is worked is what
we've been doing which in other words
I'm actually seeing a slowdown in let's
say New York City the thing that we
imposed was pretty strict sheltering in
place and closing down of you know
schools restaurants mass events and
everything but really about grocery
stores and pharmacies so I I do think
that has been working and and it's good
we're you know the question now
questions were being pushed like crazy
now to restart businesses and some
governor's who are ready to get you know
back to business like on Monday and it's
like it's it's a very unfortunate rush
in at a time where we don't really have
enough tools to actually control it and
we'll just accelerate the extent and the
duration of a resurgence of this fire so
to that point by the way our Center at
Columbia is putting out a report
that is going to the into the very
specifics about how and when can you
open a barber shop or a you know another
retail business or your local restaurant
a lot of thinking there's a lot of hot
air about all that now it means that you
know it's women like you're saying
people are protesting and blue banners
and placards and yeah yeah and you can't
you can feel for them if they're out of
a job right only feel for them yeah
totally feel for them so the governor's
have to be very careful that in their
desire to respond to legitimate very
very legitimate concerns that people
have about their income and paying the
rent but this is serious business for
people it's not just a matter of
inconvenience and changing their norms
it's a you know can I pay the rent next
week so I get all that but the question
that we have to balance is if we reopen
too quickly before we have the ability
to control spread and and even just the
basics of getting testing done that's
that's a potential disaster that nobody
wants and nobody wants to be responsible
for so we have a lot of thinking to do
and that's the basis of the report and
you're just going be coming out with
could you remind us some of us who took
biology a long time ago what is that
what are the specifics of an antibody
test what is actually going on and so
there's two kinds of tests that we're
talking about one which is referred to
as a PCR test which doesn't mean they
wanted that what that is though it
measures the presence of the virus by
looking for particles of the viruses RNA
or DNA but RNA particularly and it says
they do the test this is what the nasal
swab were they put a long swab down your
nose they get a sample of the mucous in
the back of the nose they sent it to the
lab in the lab they mix it with reagents
and they come up and they say okay this
person tested positive for the presence
of the virus the other category of tests
are the serology tests or the antibody
tests and in though
we're looking to see if you have
evidence that your body has built up a
resistance via something called
antibodies so you may not be testing
positive right now for the actual
presence of the virus with a PCR test
but if you have high antibodies that may
mean that you you had it in the past and
you've now built up resistance to it
because you now have antibodies so one
measures the test on me for the virus
and the other measures your body's
reaction to it
so you're saying to anybody that I might
have created in my own physiology to
fight a corona virus that I might have
had is it that unique for you to say you
made that anybody for this virus you can
do that well there's different kinds of
antibodies so there's something called
IgM which happens as soon as you get an
infection so as soon as you have a new
virus or bacteria that your body doesn't
like it produces some generalized
antibodies called IgM
a few weeks later it produces a much
more specific antibody to the thing that
we might be talking about like rotavirus
and that's an IgG antibody so as we get
better and better at that we're gonna
get more and more specific about oh this
antigen I mean this antibody this IgG is
specific for coronavirus so you had
corona virus even if you didn't have
symptoms and very mild symptoms we'll
know that can you imagine a near future
where we do have the antibody test or
the other test and you say okay
those you folks are immune or more
immune than others you can start going
back to work is this realistic yes it
could be realistic yeah the problem here
Neil is that we don't know how long
those anybody's will last and how
protective they'll actually be and you
know some people think that the
antibodies that you build up the corona
virus may not be as protective as we'd
like them to be and second of all even
if they are protective we don't know if
they'll be protected for a month six
months a year or whatever so this is in
the category of the great unknowns that
are really making people or work on this
uncomfortable about predicting when and
now this whole episode is going to end I
don't mean to complicate things further
but the is Kovan nineteen more or less
susceptible to mutations well compared
to other viral the common cold or
anything else yeah the corona virus is
capable on this particular one of a lot
of mutations to the point where and this
is one of the reasons why it may be
complicated to find a vaccine that works
because ever there's been significant
mutations of the virus and the point
where the vaccine that you made up was
very specific to the version six months
ago and no longer specific is obviously
a major problem for us and you know on
the other hand they could also be
creating a new vaccine every season you
like we get our annual flu shots which
hopefully everybody else certainly won't
your sophisticated listeners
we'll be getting an annual flu shot but
it may be that we'll be able to add a
coronavirus component to the annual flu
shot and that would be a great thing if
we're gonna make that work tell me about
the death undercounts that have been
reactivated well what was going on there
so I wrote an op-ed just relatively
recently that was what went into this
fact that we have I believe very
significant undercounting of the deaths
associated with Kobe 19 and there's a
couple of reasons for that number one is
we didn't start doing testing
effectively certainly in this country in
most other countries and so well after
the situation started there was just a
report in the last few days about
somebody who died in early February who
was thought to have corona virus and
there's a lot of anecdotes anecdotal
stories about people who you know had a
relative who friend who died in late
January early February who had symptoms
very consistent with corona virus but we
weren't doing testing so that's a
problem a second problem in the
undercounting is that a lot of people
are dying because of the Kobe 19
pandemic who don't actually have the
virus and let me explain so if you have
severe chest pain you're having a heart
attack and you go to an emergency room
in New York City a week and half ago
when the emergency rooms were like chaos
beyond what you can imagine you might
not get appropriate evaluation and
treatment for your symptoms in a timely
manner because the the ers were over way
over overcrowded the staff was
completely consumed with taking care of
Kovac patients so your care might be
delayed and you might not be getting
everything you need in a timely fashion
so if you die under those circumstances
the autopsy might not show evidence
kovat 19 of the coronavirus but you will
have died as a consequence of the
presence of this huge outbreak in
various cities so there's going to be a
lot of assessment ultimately of the fate
talents associated with this and by the
way that shouldn't be a unusual way to
account for things I remembered I was
young when I first heard they talk about
the lethality of a snow storm for
example yeah someone might get left out
in the cold and freeze sure but you also
the heart attacks from people shoveling
snow
exactly right the whole trickle down of
ways and means that people are touched
and affected and put in some cases
lethally but yeah before we get our
second and last break let me just ask
United States look real bad in the
numbers when it finally arrived on our
shores is there something we should have
done that didn't that we didn't do and
what countries got it right the
countries are good like South Korea like
Singapore initially Hong Kong and so on
did much more aggressive testing so that
then we were doing and there were three
types of failures that happened in the
United States that are important the
first is that we completely screwed up
the testing we just didn't get it right
we made many mistakes and we were
extremely far behind other countries
that were doing
a more appropriate amount of testing and
that lack of testing left are still in
the dark with respect to who had that
season who did not that was a big
problem the second problem was that the
messaging that came from the White House
was a freaking disorganized mess
basically and that disorganization of
messaging left the governors and mayors
have to you know improvise and make it
up on their own and we ended up with
disparate policies all over the country
and that was a mess and the third thing
is that we horrendously under
underprepared for what was happening to
the hospitals so
all the problems of personal protective
equipment like gowns and masses or that
lack of sufficient mechanical
ventilators all of this was part of a
sort of a third huge mistake that the
country made so inadequate testing bad
messaging and inadequate preparing for
the onslaught that a lot of hospitals
got in this process is you know really
among the things that we messed up
pretty badly here's something I wonder
all things considered the United States
is a pretty healthy country all things
considered and so an interesting
statistic I saw which I hadn't thought
to think about before was country by
country
how many hospital beds per capita do
they have right hops a little bits per
100,000 in the population let's say and
the United States hospital bed number
was relatively low and so what could
possibly take us by storm is anything
that ends up sending that need above the
average baseline rate and then then you
can't blame the health system for that
at that point well you use sort of you
know this blame issue is very
complicated because first of all for
business reasons a lot of hospitals make
decisions about how many beds they want
you know beds are also a big breadwinner
but on the other hand hospitals that are
underutilized like a lot of rural
hospitals just gets shut down and so
that's one thing the second thing is
that hospital systems operate much like
many businesses now in what's called
just-in-time ordering so a lot of
companies that may years ago I've had
these huge warehouses with everything
stocked that maintaining of big supplies
was costly so they use a that they maybe
only have a few days of whatever their
commodity is and then reorder so they
don't have to have massive warehouses
and hospitals are doing the same thing
in terms of their backup equipment
mechanical ventilators
and other kinds of let's say whatever
whatever it is are the comprise their
their stockpile of regular needs so that
also leaves us very vulnerable so if you
need a lot in a short period of time
and you don't have it and the
government's the federal government
stockpiles are also depleted we end up
with what we saw in New York City and
other places so it's a complicated
business but a lot of the decisions by
hospitals are not made on the basis of
oh we might get a you know a hundred
year storm or a hundred year pandemic
pop-up and we need to be ready for that
that is a stress on the budget so a lot
of that never disappears just before we
take a last break just a quick question
there's occasional talk you hear about
whether you can believe the numbers that
have come out of other countries
especially China are there any two
health professionals have any reason to
doubt the numbers that come from one
country versus another in this I think
so you know especially China has not
been exactly transparent historically
and I think we probably were late to be
informed about what was happening in
China we needed to get more of our our
professionals say from the CDC in other
places that get in there and really help
them figure out what was going on that
could have happened earlier we don't
have a real number in terms of
fatalities in China for a variety of
reasons so China's like an extreme
example of our of why we're skeptic
about sceptical about information from
other countries but Iran also and I
don't know you know it's all kinds of
political implications and geopolitical
implications of having low number versus
a high number and so on so there's a lot
of variability but there's also a lot of
variability in the populations we have
it we tend to have a much younger
population than China and some of the
countries and and you know we have
different rates of chronic illness that
we have so let's say compared to South
Korea or Japan
so on so a lot of differences make the
numbers not necessarily perfectly
compatible or comparable so we're gonna
take a quick break I'm gonna come right
back to my interview with dr. Irwin
redlener on the coronavirus stay tuned
we're back Startalk Dr Irwin redlener
director of Columbia University's
National Center for disaster
preparedness so to pick up where we left
off we're talking about reporting of
numbers around the world there's been a
rise I hate to even bring this up but
it's out there about a conspiracy
theorists let me not give them more
credence than they deserve but let me
just ask we all know in the town where
this virus first arose isn't there a CDC
kind of operation going on there a
disease lab yeah yeah yeah there isn't
and one of the you know way out there
conspiracy theories is that this virus
was developed and released in a lab in
China
or maybe was develop and then
accidentally release but a lot of people
have looked into this and the vast
majority of good I think as far as I'm
sort of all legitimate scientists have
debunked the notion that China
deliberately created this virus in this
ways of testing for that which are
pretty sophisticated I can't begin to
explain it to you but I will say that I
don't have any what I would consider to
be legitimate colleagues who think that
that actually happened in China right so
but it would but that doesn't prove that
doesn't preclude it leaking out right if
they actually developed a lesson starts
it let me let me be specific so one
thought was that it was a weaponized
virus that was intentionally created
that's that's not even where I'm going
just if you do have a viral outbreak in
a place where you have viral research
going on in labs that is almost a
coincidence too strong to ignore correct
that's contradicted by the fact that
almost every single major outbreak and
pandemic that we've had in the last 100
plus years as emanated from China
and that's because or someplace in in
Africa where these wet markets are
prevalent where people are eating you
know they eat bats and other kinds of
animals that are considered exotic and a
lot of those viruses other than the ones
that are the avian flu type virus is
that a lot of these viruses like mayors
and SARS have come from people consuming
animals that are that tend to harbor
these kinds of viruses that get mutated
away and then become transmissible among
people but yeah I don't I wouldn't put
my stock in the fact that it was even
being developed in a lab intentionally
at all but you know strange things have
happened in our world and so I I guess
we can't 100% rule it out but the
purlins the prevailing thought amongst
among actual scientists that did not
happen it's encouraging to learn also
we're kind of stuck where the public is
looking for expertise and because of the
evolution of the virus advice related to
combating the virus has evolved there I
use that word in that way so we do
remember the clarion call to not wear
masks it's not necessary you're not
gonna likely to catch it that way now
we're hearing everybody's gotta wear
masks so what what is the public
supposed to do how they supposed to
react when they see this flip-flopping
of messaging well it wasn't that many
weeks ago - by the way Neal where of the
mayor of Seattle said no gatherings of
more than 500 people are allowed and
then de Blasio days later in the mayor
of New York Bill de Blasio said no
gatherings of 500 people or more and
then other mayors were saying a hundred
people or more
and characteristic of a situation like
this where there are so many unknowns
people are saying things and especially
in the absence of central guidance from
the CDC where they say at point x you
we don't want gatherings more than 10
people that means that the mayor seattle
in the mayor of new york don't have to
sort of make it up based on whatever
their information their to inputting the
issue of masks which has you know become
sort of the national norm except nobody
at the White House press briefing
separate wears a mask er does anything
other than crowd together in front of
the microphone funny that that's not
that aside rubbing the noses and
somebody else's nose is like though they
but other than that actually I think
people end up then concluding that yes
it's better to wear masks so that you
are not inadvertently breathing in
viruses that may be in the environment
from other people and that if you are to
be infected you're not breathing out
viruses that can affect somebody else so
uh and those kinds of changes or
evolution in policy is not uncommon and
that's you know it's one of the
uncomfortable things we do have to get
used to that there's so many unknowns
that as we learn more policies will
change and will continue to change by
two last questions one is this the new
normal for us how much I said we how
much of this are we gonna have to get
used to as a permanent alteration in our
daily routines so I think this is going
to be around for a lot longer than we
may have hope for and it may be
recurrent so one of the ways I've looked
at this question is if you're 80 years
old you are likely to spend the rest of
your life for 75 or whatever it is the
rest of your life living in this kind of
very unusual abnormal world and yes you
got to get used to it if you're 25 or 45
you're still learning they have to have
to get used to what may be a very long
process but you will be around when the
light at the end of the tunnel so to
speak is actually actually appears and
we'll get back to a much more normal way
of life so depends on who you are and
what what you're dealing with but the
fact is that yeah you're gonna you know
we're gonna have to get used to this
going out for quite some time and as the
old joke goes you hope that the light in
the end of the tunnel is not the light
of an oncoming train yeah there's a
light at the end of the tunnel but it's
a really really long tunnel so my last
but my last question and you promised
but leave us with something hopeful
because you bumped us out for this whole
show give us a give us something to
think oh here's what I really I actually
think this is possible maybe it's
wishful thinking I'm calling it possible
it may be that we come out of this
entire experience with a whole new idea
of the necessity for International
Cooperation there are certain problems
that are not going to be solved by any
individual or any individual content any
specific country that dealing with the
prevention of pandemics which are global
phenomenon requires a whole lot more
International Cooperation information
sharing and research cooperation than
we've been used to but there may be
spillover so if we want to talk about
how we need international cooperation
for dealing with pandemics we also
really need it for the climate crisis
and we really need it to make sure that
we are preserving biodiversity and and I
think if we're really lucky and we work
at it we could change the dynamics of
how countries interact with each other
and end up collectively as our own late
friend Carl Sagan when what I'm sure
said and you said many times yourself
Neil that you know we're living on this
tiny speck of nothing in this vast
universe and the fact that we have these
global planetary problems that are that
need to be solved we need to get our
acts together and and do a collective
way if we want to really survive well
Erman that's the most hopeful thing i've
yet to hear about the coronavirus that
it might prep us for future challenges
that require international global
cooperation so why don't we end on that
note
Erin it's like it's great I'm delighted
and honored to
even call you a friend we've known each
other for a few decades now got through
through Carl Sagan actually I think
we'll through that collaboration exactly
was it yeah and and so thanks for I know
you were in high demand writing op-eds
and showing up on the news and delighted
you gave a little bit of your day for us
here at star talk thanks for joining us
my pleasure as always see you again good
this has been star talk I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always and
particularly perhaps now more than ever
[Applause]
[Music]